hello everyone I'm sure you all remember
a couple of months back you woke up one
day and you realize the entire world was
talking about one thing
google deepmind's artificial
intelligence alpha zero and you didn't
really you don't really know what alpha
zero was or maybe you did I I for one
didn't but I I saw that it immediately
crushed one of the strongest engines
chess engines in the world at the stock
fish and of course this was all very
interesting but no one was really that
impressed by by the fact that alpha zero
actually won that match but everyone was
more impressed by the fact how alpha
zero wanted and the moves alpha zero
made were were so human and they were
they were a lot easier to understand for
humans than for example the one the
moves for example an engine would make
but of course even if you could
understand the move there is a there's a
there's a very low chance that you would
actually play it as it's a very
complicated move so what's the idea here
the idea is after after that match alpha
zero versus dogfish off zero stopped
playing chess now alpha zero is probably
solving some of the world's greatest
problems or or maybe it's evolving into
Skynet who knows but the world saw that
there is a possibility for artificial
intelligence to really play chess at a
level that that humans deserve that
chess is played I mean we need we need
we need someone that can play chess like
alpha zero to teach us how to play like
that so here we have Leela chest zero
little a chest zero is also an
artificial a talent intelligence it's an
open source project an attempt at
computer learning it will also it she
I'm just gonna refer to it as she she's
gonna learn her teacher self how to play
chess from scratch so already I believe
she played a couple of million games and
at the moment I believe it's it's maybe
a four or five week project at the
moment so currently her playing strength
is around 1800 maybe 1919
and this year I didn't change the design
of my board this is their website the
allele hs0
project website here I will turn off my
my frame so you can see it this is just
part of the website I'm just using it to
show you what Lila can do and here you
can you can play against Lila in three
modes in ultra-fast mode and fast mode
and in slow mode but it's even better if
you download Lila to your own computer
install her and then she will start
learning and improve herself because not
everyone can afford a supercomputer like
you guys at the deepmind so alia
unfortunately has very limited resources
so the idea is every every one of us
should install Lila on your on our PC
and with time as you will be playing
games using our resource using our CPU
and GPU and those data will all merge
into one into one huge chess entity at
one point so that's basically the idea
but I will put all the links in the
description below you can check out the
website you can check out other games
Lila played so far you can you can go to
this website and play against Lila
you're also building / you can install
it on your own PC now which I believe
there is a tutorial on how to do it and
you know some general discussions on
reddit under official forum and stuff so
let's try it out I haven't installed it
yet but I will I will install her either
either today or tomorrow and then I will
probably make another video and compare
the strength when when you when she's
installed on on your own computer and
when you play a / a website so here at
first we'll start to which the ultra
fast mode so let's see the ultra fast
mode and it's interesting that since
it's an AI it's not an engine if it
plays a week it will play week like a
human it's not gonna be like fake week
moves like first you play a couple of
moves extremely strong and then you
unperfect like blunder one so let's see
what what lela lela chest zero can do
okay sorry about that yeah it seems the
interface shifted hope it's not gonna do
that every time I make a move okay
I think it's alright so since it's not
an engine since it's like self learning
AI let's let's play against Lila like we
would against a human so let's see let's
see what okay so Levi allows it let's go
for night captures on f7 and okay that's
that's pretty disappointing but that's
probably one of the reasons why you have
to install her okay but that was the
ultra fast mode let's try let's try the
fast mode
okay let's restart game and let's let's
try the fast mode here she will have a
bit more time to think and I don't think
fuel actually will make a move like this
once again okay let's let's try this
captures captures and okay let's let's
go for it again we have three ah okay
King e6 very nice so definitely
something a human would do I mean human
wouldn't go for this variation but if
you don't know the opening Z you would
definitely end up in this variation at
one point so okay I've never seen Knight
d4 I'm sure there's something very wrong
with it but instead of trying to refute
it let's let's just see how how Allah
how Allah plays the the endgame okay
let's go here check and I guess let's
just defend c2 and Castle probably go
for f4 here okay what am I missing here
I don't think I'm missing anything okay
it's a bit tricky is Lyra tricking me
and g5 off so this basically means I
just lost the piece does it does it mean
I just lost I lost the piece
well at least was the exchange so let's
okay I will I will give up the exchange
let's see how Leela will will play so
okay definitely definitely a lot
stronger in in fast mode than in super
fast mode okay pushing those pawns
definitely I like it
didn't expect didn't expect her to be
this strong at this moment so weak on
that mode
I was very strange okay okay that's a
that's a really dumb Bishop there that's
a really dumb Bishop there okay
okay I don't want to go into the corner
but don't really have a chance
okay threatening that let's just prevent
it and and try and get our night into
the game somehow Rocky one will be will
be a pretty big threat oh okay let's
let's go here and hopefully hopefully do
something probably Bishop c3 and yeah
okay she saw that that wasn't that was a
pretty cheap shot there's no really no
real way to actually exchange here okay
and I look against the bishop let's see
let's see how she wins this let's let's
try and create some sort of a castle
here okay not interested not interested
okay
huh
okay
yeah that was that was pretty bad huh
okay I will give her that guy okay okay
I will resign this since I didn't expect
her to play so well after blundering
that checkmate so let's just restart
this and use this mode again okay let's
see let's see how she'll play shall play
now okay let's let's repeat let's repeat
and and see okay I shall go she'll go
for the same okay so laughing in my face
let's go here okay now I'm gonna take
with the bishop and and see what what's
the idea here
well this night to d4 seems like a
reasonable move although I've never seen
it running with the king that's
reasonable let's let's get rid of this
night here hopefully as soon as possible
okay not really liking this bishop here
not really liking it here let's just
attack the queen first okay not really
enjoying myself here
okay captures captures okay let's let's
grab with the Queen rook f8 why not
let's get a rock into the game threaten
rookie rookie for let's let's get it in
there and can i grab on a seven then
Bishop captures on f3 is an idea Bishop
captures on f3
I can check here yeah not really not
really all that great
huh that's actually not bad
huh huh huh that's actually not bad
let's see what do you do on f4 captures
captures rook captures and if I kept
Ronny seven now can I do that then after
King moves I don't really have any
follow-ups okay let's see let's see what
she'll probably rookie - you have I mean
threatening checkmate and after I block
it what do you play that's what you play
huh okay I will take it one takes I
block
oh I've locked in Quincy one check oh I
didn't actually want to play it but I
don't think I actually had any any
choice there yeah very nice okay finish
me all right
very nice it got checkmated bye bye Lea
chess
zero so that's basically it this is Lila
and like I said in the description below
there will be all of the links that you
can use to try out Lila on the website
using ultra-fast mode as you've seen
ultra ultra fast mode really gives alia
two little resources so don't play ultra
fast mode you can use fast mode or even
slow mode where Lila will take some time
to think about her moves but they will
definitely be interesting so definitely
not not not a move order and definitely
not an opening an engine would use any
any any engine that has an opening
database would never go for this
variation would black but as you've seen
a Lila goes for it
I don't know I've never seen that 94
move probably maybe if I tried
considered it for a bit I would have
found maybe even a refutation for it but
playing it fast like this I don't know a
little it appears to be a bit stronger
than than 19-hundred but you know feel
free to try around to try out and do
share some of some of your results in
the comments section and yeah let's
let's all install her and let's create
let's create another alpha 0 so we can
once again have a decent a legal a zero
just this time versus stockfish and
we're stockfish can maybe maybe play the
the the last version of stockfish on a
really nice piece of hardware so yeah
that's Lee Lash's 0 I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon I
probably would another video from Greg
HS plastic